hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how to identify key genes
with Chris Burke at nine and shrna
screams my name is Dan Pham of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by GE healthcare GE
healthcare continues to be the industry
leader in the field of RNA chemistry RNA
AI biology and high-throughput screening
and partners with the RNA eye screening
community through participation and the
RNA I Global Initiative with GE
healthcare you get access to the largest
and most complete portfolio of
innovative and technologically advanced
tools for gene silencing gene expression
and gene editing for more information
please visit www.thegrape.com by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems using or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this webinar has been
approved for continuing education
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I would
like now to turn it over to our speaker
dr. Anya Smith director of R&D at Dharma
Khan part of GE healthcare hello and
welcome everyone thank you soon for that
introduction and thank you for joining
us today as you just heard my name is
Anya Smith I'm the director of R&D at GE
healthcare and I oversee our R&D team
we're developing new dharmic on products
and also demonstrating applications and
workflows you
existing dharmic on reagents so today
I'll be presenting some basics of pooled
lentiviral screening workflows that are
applicable not only to short hairpin or
shRNA screens which have been around for
a long time but also to the more recent
CRISPR cash nine single guide or sgrna
screens in particular I'll discuss
important considerations that can impact
whether you have a successful pool
lentiviral screen or not and also some
tools that we have that can help to
ensure successful screening so shortly
after the discovery of RNA interference
in mammalian cells it became clear that
RNA I could be used to perform genome
scale or even genome-wide
loss-of-function screens in order to
identify new targets or elucidate
biological pathways and networks in an
unbiased fashion so the first
large-scale RNA I screen using expressed
shrnas was published in 2004 followed by
the first whole genome screen using
synthetic SI RNAs in 2007 of course
since then there have been countless
published RNA I screens studying many
different biologies using both si RNAs
and SH RNAs and are now are nai screens
today remain a standard tool for
functional genomic studies now with the
recent discovery of CRISPR caste 9 as a
powerful tool for creating gene knock
outs in mammalian cells it didn't take
long for researchers to apply the
history of RNA AI to CRISPR cast 9 and
start performing genome scale knockout
screens so the first screens were
published in early 2014 and since then
of course additional screens continue to
be formed performed and published now
one thing to note is that RNA AI screens
have been performed as both a raid and
pool screens using both synthetic and
vector based reagents whereas the CRISPR
cast 9 screens have today been performed
as polled screens using vector based
cast 9 and vector base single guide or
SG RNAs
so the for the purposes of this webinar
I'll be focusing on vector-based pooled
screening specifically using Lent evarro
shrna and lentiviral sgrna pools so to
start I'd like to review some general
features of pooled lentiviral screens
whether there are shRNA or sgrna screens
so when performing pooled screens cells
are transduced with pooled lentiviral
constructs in cell culture dishes and
then the transduced cells are subjected
to a phenotypic screen now these
phenotypes are typically those that can
be selected or sorted in order to
distinguish your hits from non hits and
the way you do that is by determining
whether your constructs are being
enriched or depleted in your cell
population of course an advantage to the
lentiviral screening approach is that
lentiviral shrna and sgrna pooled
screens can be used in difficult to
transact cells and can also be used to
assay for phenotypes that require long
term silencing so here's an overview of
the pooled screening workflows for
shrnas and SG RNAs as I mentioned
previously in both types of screens a
pool of lentiviral constructs is
transduced into the population of cells
now the transduction should be at a low
multiplicity of infection or mo eye such
that a single cell will receive a single
SH RNA or a single sgrna construct the
cell population is then selected with
antibiotics in order to select for cells
that have been transduced and then the
population is expanded at this point the
primary screen is performed so for the
primary screen a reference sample or t0
sample is taken and then selective
pressure is applied to the experimental
sample or the t1 sample now in order to
determine which shrnas or which SG RNAs
have been depleted or enriched
high-throughput sequencing or
next-generation sequencing of the
genomic DNA from the two samples the t0
and the t1 is
formed and analyzed now one important
difference between the shrna and the
sgrna screening workflows is that shrnas
use the endogenous mammalian RNA AI
machinery to find and then silenced the
target transcripts with CRISPR cast 9
however the SG RNAs need the bacterial
protein cast 9 to find and cleave the
target genomic sequence so in order to
do sgrna pooled screens you need to
provide cast 9 exogenously so for
screening purposes we recommend that the
cast 9 expression cassette is integrated
and then stabili expressed in the cells
that will be used for screening in order
to do this lentiviral particles
containing cast 9 are transduced into
the cells then these cells are
antibiotics selected and expanded so
that you have a sufficient number for
the screen these cells then stabili
expressing cast 9 can then be used in
the screening workflow shown on the
right that I already walked you through
so the workflow that I discussed just
discussed are relatively straightforward
but there are multiple parameters that
should be evaluated before you start
your screen in order to make sure that
your screen is successful so I'll focus
on these considerations in the next few
slides okay first before I do that I
want to just take a moment and go over
some terminology to remember so that
we're all on the same page the first
distribution of the library when we talk
about distribution of the library we're
referring to how evenly each of the
individual constructs is represented in
the original pool it's desirable to have
a very tight distribution where ideally
every construct is represented at a
one-to-one ratio
now fold coverage or fold representation
is how many times each individual
construct is represented in the t0
population and as I'll show you the fold
representation it's very important to
ensure meaningful results from your
screen mo Y or multiplicity of infection
is the ratio of lentiviral particles to
cells
so for example an mo eye of ten means
that on average each cell will be
transduced with ten lentiviral particles
and have ten integration events a
functional titer is the number of
lentiviral particles per volume that
have the ability to transduce cells and
then a functional self specific titer is
corrected for the relative transduction
efficiency for your cells of interest
okay so I'm now going to talk about some
important considerations for pooled
screening I'm going to mention them here
and then discuss them further throughout
the rest of the webinar so the first
thing is your library design it's
essential to have a well-designed
library for transduction so some of the
things to consider is the pool size or
the number of constructs in each pool
and this is important for obtaining a
high fold representation the depth of
coverage or the number of constructs
targeting each gene is also important
and has an impact on the pool size as
well also important of course are
controls
particularly to have negative controls
and gene specific or positive controls
included in each pool significantly all
of the constructs in each pool must be
represented equally in order to avoid
bias and to ensure proper interpretation
of your results from the screen and
finally of course it's important to
ensure that the constructs in your pool
are functional whether they are shRNA or
sgrna constructs next when performing
the screen you should maintain a high
fold representation throughout the
entire screen and I'll talk about this
more throughout the webinar we recommend
at least 1,000 fold representation other
considerations for performing the screen
include the type of phenotypic selection
to apply are you going to use antibiotic
are you doing cell sorting or some type
of other selection and then whether your
genes of interest are going to be
enriched or depleted in your screen and
then of course the specifics of your
assay what cells are you going to use
what time point is your
one going to be and are you going to be
treating yourselves in some matter
finally it's important to perform your
screen with biological replicates a
minimum of two replicates should be
included and we recommend triplicates if
possible finally after the screen has
been performed and the sample is
collected
next generation sequencing libraries are
generated and multiplexing is what we
recommend to save time and cost again
it's also important to maintain the fold
representation of the screen during the
PCR amplification steps because we know
that PCR itself can introduce biases so
to do that you should use optimized
primers as well as conditions in the PCR
to avoid this additional bias once the
next-generation sequencing data is in
hand determining your hit identification
of course is very important and so you
need to consider what the appropriate
cutoff thresholds and what statistical
models you want to use in order to
really make sense of your data okay so
let's start out by talking about library
design so as I said the first step in
ensuring a successful pooled screen is
that you're using an optimal library so
that means the library consists of
shrnas or SG RNAs that are going to be
expressed well and they are highly
functional for transcript knockdown or
gene knockout
so for shRNA pooled libraries we have
the dharmic own smart vector lentiviral
shRNA platform and highlights of the
library are shown here in particular the
smart vector platform has a choice of
multiple promoters for constitutive
shown here on the top or inducible shown
here on the bottom shrna expression and
we know that expression of an shRNA or
any gene for that matter is highly
dependent on the promoter used and some
promoters just work much better in a
certain cell line compared with a
different promoter so we offer a choice
of promoters and recommend that you use
the empirically determined optimal
promoter for the cell line that you're
using for your
pulled screen we also have a choice of
two fluorescent reporters turbo GFP or
turbo RFP or no reporter option as well
all vectors contain a Pyramus and
selectable marker that you can use for
your screen now regarding functionality
of the shRNA designs in the library our
shrnas are designed within our patented
micro RNA based scaffold this allows for
a highly efficient processing of the
shrnas using the endogenous RNA AI
pathway in addition our shrnas are
designed based on our rational design
algorithm that we've developed and
validated in-house so together this
results in highly functional shrna
constructs and vector design for gene
knockdown now we have multiple smart
vector shRNA pooled libraries to choose
from some of which are shown in this
table so in the table I'm showing you
the library collection name the number
of targeted gene and that genes in that
collection and then the number of pools
and the average number of constructs per
pool for that collection as well now as
you can see we limit the number of
constructs per pool to around 10 or
11,000 max and as you'll see in later
slides the size of the lentiviral pool
is very important and does affect a
number of different parameters in the
screening experimental design the bottom
line is pool sizes of greater than ten
or eleven thousand may result in screens
that are just logistically and
practically really hard to perform the
shrna libraries are all provided as high
titer purified concentrated lentiviral
particles with a titer of five times ten
to the eighth base transducing units per
mil and that's a functional titer we
determine in HEK to nine three T cells
the pools have an average of 7.6 shrnas
designs per gene and again the designs
are based on our rationally designed
shRNA specific algorithm and included in
the pool are multiple negative and
positive control
now each of these pre-made libraries are
also available for mouth and we also are
able to make custom human mouse or rat
pools upon request as well okay moving
on to our sgrna lentiviral pools we
offer the DAR makan editor lenta Vario
sgrna platform which consists of a cast
9 nuclease and the sgrna now we offer a
2 vector system where the cast 9
nuclease and the sgrna are on separate
vectors and this allows you to establish
a cell line that stabili expresses cast
9 prior to the transduction of the pool
now similar to our smart vector platform
we offer the cast 9 nuclease with a
choice of several different promoters so
that you're able to use the promoter
that's best for your cell line and this
ensures the best expression of the cast
9 nucleus and we know that optimal cast
9 expression is really important to
ensure efficient gene knockouts the SG
RNAs on the other hand are expressed
from a u6 promoter that works
universally well across cell lines to
express short RNA sequences the sgrna
design in the pools is based on our
editor rational design algorithm and
we've developed this algorithm and it's
designed for successful protein knockout
not just creation of double strand
breaks and that of course is important
if you're looking to identify phenotypes
now of course the cast 9 nucleus and the
sgrna vectors do have different
selectable markers so that you can make
that in cast 9 integrated stable cell
line first and then select 4 cells
transduced with the SG rnas during the
screen itself ok also similar to our
smart vector pooled libraries we have
multiple editor lentiviral single guide
RNA pooled libraries to choose from for
human Mouse and rats and again some of
these are shown in this table so again
the name of the collection the number of
targeted genes and then the number of
pools and the number of sgrna constructs
smaller library subsets are also
available and we can also make custom
pools upon request as well
the sgrna libraries are also provided as
high titer purified concentrated
lentiviral particles with a titer
greater than 5 times 10 to the 8th
transducing units per mil the pools have
an average of 9.8 pre-designed sgrna s
per gene and again this is using our
Dharma Khan editor algorithm and we also
include multiple negative and positive
controls ok so I just want to take a
minute and talk a little bit more about
the use of controls to normalize and
compare your screening results the
gene-specific controls include essential
or viability genes that can provide
confidence that your screen has worked
since some of these are expected to be
depleted by the t1 time point
additionally the gene specific controls
include some reference genes that are
typically not going to change in
abundance for most phenotypic assays so
these serve as good controls as well the
negative controls that we can include
are designed bioinformatics to not
target any gene in the human mouse or
rat genome these are important for
normalization and can be an indication
of the noise of the screen which can be
used to establish the cutoff criteria
for hit identification importantly all
the gene specific and the negative
controls are the same composition as the
experimental shrna or sgrna constructs
so they indeed do serve as good controls
ok as I mentioned before one important
consideration when evaluating pooled
libraries for screening is to know
whether all of the constructs whether
they are shrnas or SG RNAs whether
they're equally represented in the pool
if they're not equally represented in
the pool you'll introduce bias in your
screen and this can greatly affect your
screening data quality so the top graph
is an example of poor construct
distribution where you can see there's a
wide distribution in the abundance of
the constructs and many of them here
indicated in
red are present at low abundance and
therefore these can be lost during the
screen this would result in depletion of
these constructs during the screen and
they would appear as hits if you're
looking for depleted hits when in fact
they would really be false positives now
the lower graph shows a narrow or tight
distribution of all the constructs in
the pool and this library will result in
superior screening data with far fewer
potential false positives now as part of
our products you see we assess the
representation of constructs in the
library pools using next-generation
sequencing we do this both for the
glycerol stocks that we develop in-house
as well as for the final lentiviral pool
that's delivered to you in particular as
shown here we analyze the next-gen
sequencing data of our pools and look at
what the distribution is for 70% of the
population shown here with the blue
lines or 90% of the population shown
here with the red lines so here you can
see for this pool of 7519 SG RNAs
70% of the constructs in the lentiviral
pool have a two-fold difference in
abundance so the distribution is very
narrow and tight which is good looking
at the 90% data we see that 90% of the
constructs in the population are within
4 fold of each other in abundance again
showing that the distribution among the
constructs in this pool is very tight
and the constructs are essentially
represented equally importantly our
libraries also have high recovery of the
constructs between the glycerol stocks
and the packaging of the lentivirus
now in this library shown there's
greater than 99.5 percent recovery of SG
RNAs at the T 0 time point indicating
that we have not lost constructs during
creation or transduction of the library
ok so we've chosen the optimal library
design for our screen and we're ready to
move on to performing the screen so what
do we need to keep in mind when
performing and then analyzing the screen
first one consideration is a type of
asset you are going to use for the pool
screen as I mentioned the phenotype for
pool screens must be amenable to some
sort of selection or sorting in order to
be able to identify the enriched and
depleted constructs between the T 0 and
the T 1 samples again in the screening
workflow the lentiviral pools are
transduced into cells and then the
reference or the T 0 sample is collected
then some type of selective pressure is
applied on the experimental sample or
the T 1 sample and then at the end of
the screen you want to be able to
identify constructs that have changed in
abundance between the T 0 and the T 1
samples these should be the constructs
that are affected by the treatment you
applied now here on the right we've
listed some examples of the types of
phenotypic assays that are amenable to
pooled screens cell viability either
through cell survival or drug treatment
is a common phenotype that has been used
in multiple published pooled screens
other acids such as cell behavior or
cell sorting using a fluorescence or
other type of reporter as well as in
vivo screens have also been used and
published in the example screens that
I'll discuss at the end of this
presentation we use cell viability as
our phenotypic screen okay another very
important consideration for pooled
screens or really any screen for that
matter is reproducibility in other words
you want to ensure that the results you
obtain are robust and reproducible you
want the hit that you discovered in your
screen to show up again as a hit if the
screen were repeated on a different day
so we've looked extensively at
parameters that affect the
reproducibility of pooled shrna screens
and have published our work for the data
shown here and the reference is here at
the bottom of the slide so what we found
is that not surprisingly there are
multiple steps in the pooled screening
workflow that can affect data quality
and reproducibility we'll discuss some
of the major themes here during the
webinar and I highly encourage you to
read the
we're in full to learn more to one of
our primary conclusions in our
publication is that fold representation
of each construct during screening
greatly affects the screen data quality
so again fold representation is defined
by how many times each construct is
represented in the t0 population so here
in the cartoon show each of the four
particular shrna constructs which
hopefully you can see our different
colors are present in an equal number of
cells so for example at one hundred or
five hundred fold representation these
four constructs would each be in 100 or
500 different cells in the cell
population now as shown on the right
when looking at replicates a and B for a
screen performed with 100 cells per
shrna compared with a screen performed
with 500 cells per shRNA we see the
Pearson correlation or the R value is
much higher in the five hundred fold
representation screen where we have an R
value of 0.67 compared to the lower R
value of 0.4 one in the 100 fold
representation screen there this
indicates higher reproducibility between
replicates with higher fold
representation in the graph shown here
we compare different fold
representations from 100 to 1,000 fold
representation and we looked at the
effect on reproducibility again using
the Pearson correlation so as you can
see the Pearson correlation increases
with increased fold representation and
with 1,000 fold representation the R
value is highly significant at 0.99 4 in
addition you can see a substantial
increase between the 500 and the 1,000
fold representation samples and this is
why we recommend at least 1,000 fold
representation in a pooled screen it's
really to obtain high-quality and
reproducible data now equally important
to keep high reproducibility is to
maintain this high fold representation
in the PCR steps when you amplify the
genomic DNA for next-generation
sequencing now this typically requires
setting up multiple PCR reactions in
order to have the proper amount of DNA
represented so for example with a small
pooled library with only 1000 shrnas or
SG RNAs in order to maintain that 1,000
fold representation here in the PCR 6.6
micrograms of input genomic DNA is
required in order to successfully
amplify this much starting material the
genomic DNA must be divided into
multiple PCR reactions this is because
we know that too much genomic DNA
template in a PCR reaction can inhibit
amplification and this you can see here
in the lower gel image where when you
have the larger amounts of input you
don't get amplification of your band so
the amount of genomic DNA per PCR
reaction is 825 nano grams for 100%
amplification efficiency so for 6.6
micrograms of the input genomic DNA that
is required for 1,000 fold
representation you'll need to perform
eight PCR reactions per genomic DNA
sample we've also designed and tested
the PCR primers and optimized the PCR
conditions including the enzyme amount
the amount of genomic DNA inputs as I
just showed you whether or not you need
to add additives as well as the cycle
numbers for the PCR in order to amplify
shrnas and sgrna without an energy bias
so here what I'm showing you is the
result of the law counts obtained from
next-gen sequencing after PCR
amplification with using fusion
polymerase and using the optimized PCR
primers and conditions as you can see
the PCR primers do not show an shrna
specific energy bias and we obtain
equivalent law counts regardless of the
free energy which is good
okay so earlier I mentioned that the
size of the shRNA or the sgrna pool has
an impact on the practical aspects to
performing an effective screen the
widest pool size matter well in order to
have each cell expressing a single
construct in order to ensure that the
knockdown or the knock out of a single
gene in a particular cell is responsible
for the resulting phenotype we recommend
performing transduction at a low mo eye
of 0.3 or less now using the Poisson
distribution this results in
approximately 22% of cells having a
single integrins now in order to
determine how many cells are needed for
a specific cool you multiply the number
of constructs in the lentiviral pool by
the desired fold representation and this
then gives you the desired number of
cells with lentiviral integrations now
you then need to take into account the
Poisson distribution I just mentioned
where we know that only 22% of cells
will have a lentiviral integration and
so you need to divide the desired number
of cells with lentiviral integrations by
the proportion of cells that will have
lentiviral integrations which in this
example you would be dividing by 0.2 to
this then gives you the total number of
cells required at the time of
transduction okay so to provide some
real numbers to this here are some
example calculation so if you have a
pool of 1,000 constructs and you're
using five hundred fold representation
you'll need five times ten to the fifth
lentiviral integration events with an ml
Y of 0.3 you'll need 2.3 million cells
to perform your transduction this can
typically be achieved using 1/10
centimeter tissue culture dish per
sample and of course this is cell
type-specific
if you want to have a fold
representation of 1,000 in order to have
that higher quality data you'll need 210
centimeter tissue culture dishes of
cells to transduce for each sample
so you can quickly see that in order to
maintain sufficient fold representation
the number of required cell plates will
increase significantly with larger pool
sizes this results not only in more cell
culture dishes but also more media more
incubator space etc now we also
recommend a minimum of two biological
replicates per condition so the overall
number will be doubled or ideally
tripled based on replicas so this is a
reason why our maximum pool size is
approximately 10,000 shRNA or sgrna
constructs per pool it's really to help
you keep the logistics of performing
screens manageable particularly when
using that recommended high fold
representation for the best data quality
so I've just shown you one example for
the calculations needed to determine the
required number of cells for
transduction at the start of the screen
but of course there also are additional
parameters that need similar
calculations these include the number of
samples needed for the genomic DNA for T
0 and T 1 samples the number of PCR
samples you need and how many samples
can be multiplexed for next gen
sequencing analysis so unfortunately I
won't have time today to provide
examples for each one of these
calculations however we have made a very
useful Excel spreadsheet that is
available on our website so it's
available at these URLs here the
spreadsheet itself is called pooled
screening protocol tracking worksheet
and this file can be used as a benchtop
guide for all of the calculations
required for our pooled screening
reagents so here's a screenshot of the
worksheet where you can input your
values in the light blue boxes and then
the output values from the calculations
in the worksheet are displayed in the
light gray boxes so here you can see
where you can input values for your
transduction conditions including cell
density as well as titer of your pooled
library so in this example I'm showing
you a screenshot of the worksheet for
the editor lentiviral sgrna pooled
library but we also have one for the
smart vector in lentiviral shRNA pooled
library as well
okay so here's an example where you can
use the worksheet to enter in Section F
the fold representation during
transduction the number of biological
replicates as well as the number of
sgrna per pooled library so if we enter
1000 as our fold representation 2 as our
number of biological replicates and
we're using a library with 10,000 730
sgrna constructs and we're also using
@mo i of 0.3 here the worksheet then
provides calculated values in the light
gray boxes for parameters such as the
number of cells required at the time of
transduction which in this case will be
around four point eight times ten to the
seventh cells in addition the worksheet
also provides output values for the PCR
amplification steps including the amount
of genomic DNA required to maintain fold
representation so for this example with
10,000 sgrna library at 1,000 fold
representation you see approximately 71
micrograms of genomic DNA is needed to
maintain the 1,000 fold representation
and this would then require 86 PCR
reactions per sample also calculated
here is the number of sample indices
that can be multiplexed and run per Lane
for high-throughput sequencing of the
samples so here if you input your
expected reads you'll see that in this
example you can multiplex 19 samples so
they can so these 19 samples can be run
together in a lane which significantly
decreases the cost of analysis of the
pooled screening data now as I mentioned
most readouts from the pool screens do
use next-generation sequencing to
determine the shrna or sgrna sequences
that are enriched or depleted in the
population following that selective
pressure that you applied during your
screen so here's an overview of the
next-gen sequencing compatible protocol
that we provide both for shrna as well
as SG
RNA screens so you can see from this
overview that the protocols are very
similar but they do differ slightly the
protocol uses PCR primers that we have
specifically designed to amplify
constructs with minimal bias and we also
provide optimized PCR conditions to
ensure sufficient amplification with
minimal bias as well the primers are
also indexed to allow for multiplexing
of samples on the Illumina flow cell and
construct specific sequencing and
indexing primers are provided as well
for sample deconvolution so to summarize
this section of the presentation I hope
I've convinced you of the importance of
using high quality libraries in pooled
screening experiments these libraries
will have efficient and specific
constructs they'll include multiple gene
specific and negative controls and they
also should have a tight distribution
for equal construct abundance and also a
limited pool size with high titers so
that you can achieve that high fold
representation for the greatest
reproducibility we've also provided
multiple tools that are available on our
website such as the calculation
worksheet I showed and we also have
experimentally validated protocols as
well as the reagents such as the
unbiased PCR amplification primers for
next-generation sequencing and these
will all help you have a successful
screen we also have bioinformatic
analysis protocols for analyzing pooled
screening data and again I highly
recommend that you read through our
publication on this topic to learn more
okay so now let's talk about a couple of
real screens that we've performed in our
R&D group I'll start with presenting
results from a screen using our smart
vector shrna pooled library targeting
kinase genes so here's an overview of
the experimental workflow we used as I
said the smart vector lentiviral shrna
pooled protein kinase library it targets
702 kinase genes and consists of
approximately 5,600 shRNA control
we use this library to transduce a you
to OS cell line and we used an mo i of
0.3 and a fold representation of 1000
the next day the transduce cells were
selected with Purim Ison for two days
and then the cells were split and the t0
sample was harvested the experimental
samples were maintained in Purim Ison
for an additional 14 days as our
Selective pressure and then the t1
sample was harvested and the genomic DNA
was isolated from both t0 and t1
the vector that we used in this
experiment included an RFP fluorescent
reporter therefore we could use this to
monitor the efficiency of transduction
which again we expected to be about 22%
since we used an mo eye of 0.3 now as
you can see after 2 days of pure mice
and selection 100% RFP positive cells
are obtained and then these cells are
selected through the t1 time point of 14
days of selection once the t1 time point
was harvested we amplified the genomic
DNA from both the t0 and t1 samples and
again we use those PCR conditions and
reagents where we could maintain the
1000 fold representation and then we
perform the next generation sequencing
on an Illumina platform in order to
determine the relative abundance of SH
RNAs in each sample as you can see when
plotting the log mean signal intensity
or the log mean counts comparing t 1 to
t 0 you're able to identify both
enriched and depleted shrnas we then
analyze our data further for depleted
shrnas in order to identify genes that
when silenced negatively affect cell
viability now before we look at the
results of the screen one of the things
we look at initially when analyzing the
data is the reproducibility between
biological replicates so shown here are
the counts per construct for replicate a
and replicate B and this graph shows
really high reproducibility between
replicates
with an R value of 0.9 7
next we determined which constructs we
would consider hits we identified hits
by how strongly and how significantly
the experimental constructs are depleted
at the t1 time point compared to the
constructs in the t0 time point and we
considered construct significance if
they were at least two fold depleted and
had an adjusted p-value of less than
0.05 we then determined the z-score or
the number of standard deviations away
from the mean for each construct so
shown here is a graph with the z score
on the y-axis and the gene names on the
x axis for 29 genes that we identified
that had two or more shrna constructs
that were significantly depleted in our
screen so in this graph the red shows
the significant hits and the blue are
the nan heads now if you look at the far
right of this graph we have plotted all
of our negative controls and you can see
that in this screen 99 of the 100
negative controls were not significant
by our cutoff criteria giving an
indication that we do have low noise in
the screen next I'll go over a similar
screen we perform this time using SG
RNAs to target target kinase genes for
functional protein knockouts
so in this pooled screen we use the
editor lentiviral single guide RNA
pooled protein kinase library this
library targets 700 kinase genes and
consists of approximately 7500 SG RNAs
we use this library to transduce a you
to OS cell line that we had previously
made so that it stabili expresses caste
9 and so this cell line we transduced at
an mo eye of 0.3 and we used a fold
representation of 1000 the next day
transduced cells were selected with pure
myosin for one day and then the cells
were split and the t0 sample was
harvested the experimental samples were
maintained in pure mice and for an
additional seven days similar to the
pooled smart vector shRNA screen we took
genomic DNA from the
to zero and the t1 time points from the
editor sgrna screen we harvested that
genomic DNA and amplified it again under
conditions in the PCR where we're
maintaining the 1,000 fold
representation and then we perform next
generation sequencing on an Illumina
platform we also analyze these data
specifically looking at depleted sgrna
constructs in order to identify hits
that negatively affect cell viability
again we looked at reproducibility of
our biological replicates so here's the
reproducibility of the t1 biological
replicas and again we have high
reproducibility with an r-value of 0.98
we then moved on to identify hits so
similar to the shRNA screens we
identified the sgrna hits based on how
strongly and how significantly the
constructs are depleted at the t1 time
point compared to the t0 sample in this
case we considered construct significant
if they were at least one point five
fold depleted and had an adjusted
p-value of less than 0.05 in the sgrna
screen we identified 68 genes that had
at least three sgrna constructs that met
our significance criteria so shown here
are the z-scores or the number of
standard deviations away from the mean
for each construct with the significant
hits shown in red and the non hits in
blue again if we look at the far right
where we have all of the negative
controls you see that in this screen
none of the negative controls were
significantly depleted indicating that
we have very low noise in this screen so
how do the results compare between the
pooled shrna and the pooled sgrna
screens so here's a comparison of the
depletion hits between the two screens
the first thing you probably notice is
that we did identify more hits in the
sgrna screen than the shrna screen
we also found 70 17 hits that were
identified in both screens and the gene
names of the 17 hits in common are shown
on the right and for both the shRNA and
the sgrna screens there were hits that
were non-overlapping in each screen so
although there are hits in common
clearly knocking out kinase genes is
different than knocking down kinase
genes in a viability screen but should
we really expect the results to the data
to be the same so here's where we need
to think about the mechanisms and the
differences between the two technologies
so as summarized in this table adapted
from a review we published in nucleic
acids research last year RNA I is a
knockdown of the messenger RNA using
endogenous RNA AI machinery while the
CRISPR caste 9 system is knocking out a
gene using an exogenous system knocking
down a gene is transient compared to
knocking out a gene and this can be
particularly important when establishing
time points for a screening experiment
now it is possible that the overall
higher number of hits that we saw using
the sgrna library could be due to having
complete knockout of a gene compared to
knockdown of the gene when using the
shRNA library another difference between
the two technologies to keep in mind is
the efficiency of each system with
shrnas you can typically achieve greater
than 75% knock down while the efficiency
of gene knockout in a cell population is
relatively lower but once achieved the
effect is permanent so overall these are
both powerful tools to discover gene
function in cellular pathways and
disease and which type of screen shrna
or sgrna that you should choose will
really depend on your biological system
and the experimental questions you are
looking to answer so in closing I hope
that I've shown you two different
lentiviral pooled screening platforms
and the important considerations for a
successful screen and hit identification
for both the listed here on this slide
is our website where you can find many
resources
we have technical manuals with detailed
protocols recommendations and data
analysis tools we also have quick
reference protocols and the calculation
tools that I showed you and discussed
here in this webinar as well as guides
for next-generation sequencing please
also feel free to contact our technical
support team at the email address shown
here and with that I'd be happy to
answer any of your questions and thank
you again for attending today's webinar
Thank You Anya for that fantastic
presentation while we're getting ready
for the Q&A session two polling
questions will appear on your screen
will appreciate your answer to these
questions so we can follow up
appropriately with you Thank You fruit
for that so during the
question-and-answer session I would like
to remind our audience of how to submit
questions you can do so by typing them
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can so our first question or Anya is
how do you I choose between an shRNA and
SG in our RNA full screen yeah that's a
good question and one that we hear a lot
so it really depends on the sensitivity
of your assay and the types of gene
effects you're looking for so again
specifically whether knockdown is
sufficient for your desired genotype or
whether your phenotype would require a
complete gene knockout so for example if
you're interested in identify new drug
targets knockdown might be a more
relevant phenotype than knockout since
we know that most drugs act by not
completely knocking out their target
certainly recent publications that
compared both types of pool screens have
shown that sgrna screens have higher
sensitivity or penetrance due to
knockout vs. knockdown great thank you
our next question is from a viewer who
says I would like to do a pool screen
but I'm not comfortable with performing
next-generation sequencing do you have a
service for this
no we don't provide next-generation
sequencing as a service but we do
provide the next-generation sequencing
primers and the detailed library
preparation protocols that I mentioned
and we also do have recommendations for
next-gen sequencing providers that can
do this work one thing to note is that
if you have access to a core next-gen
sequencing facility most of these core
facilities are able to perform this type
of sequencing it is fairly standard and
then for analysis of the next-gen
sequencing data we do have the
bioinformatics analysis protocol that's
available on our website alright next
you're asked why do we need to perform
the transduction so that there's only
one integral in each cell so we
recommend doing the transduction at that
low mo I that I mentioned so there's
only one integrins in each cell and
because this ensures that the phenotype
that you're seeing results from that
construct targeting one gene and the
cell enrichment and depletion in the
population can be clearly analyzed if
you were to have more than one
integration per cell this can
potentially result in a greater number
of false positives wait so the next
question goes back to biological
replicates and the viewer asks do you
really need multiple biological
replicates for the experiment yeah
having more replicates per screen can
account for experimental variability
that we know exists from from day to day
and we recommend at least two
experimental replicates for a pooled
screen however one thing I did want to
point out is that in our publication in
the journal biomolecular screening we
actually found that it's more important
to have higher fold representation
rather than having multiple replicates
in order to get better results so if you
are limited in
in your cells or your assay in terms of
the number of biological rep replicates
it is more important to have that higher
fold representation ideally you'd want
both but if you had to choose that
higher fold representation is more
important so another view RS I have my
own gene list that I'm interested in can
you make a pooled library with that yes
we can certainly make custom libraries
for both shrnas and SG RNAs again you
can contact our technical support team
or go to our website for more
information on those custom libraries or
next your ass you said you have about 10
sgrna per gene why do you need so many
yeah the reason that we developed our
pools with 10 sgrna spur gene is to be
able to provide greater confidence in
the screening results based on this
depth of coverage so for example if the
library only had two sgrna per gene and
if only one gave you a phenotype and the
other didn't it'd be hard for you to
determine whether this was a high
confidence hit or not so with more
reagents per gene you can have more
confidence in your heads if multiple
constructs do result in your phenotype
our next few reps as I've never done a
pooled screen before but it seems like
this might be feasible in my lab how
hard is it to get started ah so I don't
think it's hard to get started and
clearly there are multiple examples in
the literature so multiple labs are
doing these types of screens of course
there are some basic requirements needed
like tissue culture capabilities and the
ability to work with lentiviral
particles at your institution in the US
this requires biosafety level 2 tissue
culture which is actually the same
requirement as for culturing HeLa cells
in terms of logistics many screens can
be performed using 10 centimeter tissue
culture dishes and the number of dishes
can all fit in wanting to Bator so it's
I think it's definitely feasible in many
labs that's great
our next viewer says all right yeah did
you sell the glycerol stocks of the pool
so that I can make my move into viral
particles no we actually only offer the
pools as package lentiviral particles
and part of the reason for this is that
like I said we do all of the QC I talked
about and we provide all of this QC to
you with the library and this really
ensures that you you're starting off
with a high quality library we've done a
lot of optimization internally and we've
optimized the lentiviral packaging
process to ensure that we get a very
tight distribution of the library we
also can get really high titer particles
and like I said those two things are
really important to get that high fold
representation and we do get almost 100%
recovery of the constructs put in the
into the pool once packaged so these
lentiviral particles
libraries are really high quality
libraries for you to start your screen
with great our next participant says
it's hard for me to get a lot of stone
if I only have enough cells for 60 full
representation will my screen still work
yeah 50 fold representation that's
definitely not ideal and it probably
will require repeating the screen to get
more confidence in your hit lit list
it's likely that you'll have more false
positives and false negatives in your
screen which ultimately means that
you'll probably be following up on genes
that are not true heads and it's quite
possible that you'll miss genes that may
be true hits if you use only a 50 fold
representation beam
okay so our next viewer says I work
primary I work in primary cells that are
hard to culture what is your
recommendation for screening yeah
primary cells are tricky so what we
would recommend is that you run the
screen in a surrogate cell line that
closely resembles your primary cells but
are actually easier to culture and then
as part of the follow-up you can
look further at your high confidence
hits in your primary cells to examine
the role of these genes in that setting
of the more relevant setting of primary
cells Thanks
we have time for one more question and
the viewer says I'm interested in
performing a full screen but I've never
worked with lentiviral particles what I
need to get started yes so we recommend
starting small first one of the things
we recommend is to determine the optimal
promoter for your cell type and then use
non targeting and a positive control to
determine functional titer for your cell
line and then of course the optimal
growth and delivery conditions for
yourself
thank you so much for those and answers
if you submitted a question through the
Q&A button and it was not answered
someone will get back to you regarding
your inquiry if you have further
questions that you did not submit during
this broadcast please email them to TIA
Dharma Khan at GE comm with the
questions done I would just like to ask
our speaker for any final comments yeah
I just want to say thank you to everyone
who's attended I hope it's been helpful
webinar for you and I wish you much
success in your next pooled screen thank
you I would also like to thank our
sponsor GE healthcare for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through July of 2016 you receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event thank you
see you again next time and goodbye